[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number 12
will animals adapt to climate change
scientists are telling us right now that
they suspect that in the future as the
climate continues to change some species
will go extinct others will adapt and
still others will actually thrive
they're going to do better in the new
environments if nothing else change
except for the climate these things will
happen of course lots of things are
changing
humans are building larger and larger
cities and we're you know inventing new
pesticides and so on so there's lots of
things that can change the predictions
that scientists have but the reason that
scientists believe that some organisms
will go extinct while others will thrive
is because they've been watching climate
change now for 25 years and we've been
monitoring wildlife populations and we
have seen some organisms die off some
species go extinct we've seen some adapt
they've actually evolved in some cases
at at the level of their genes and we
have seen others thrive so to try and
help understand what types of organisms
we expect to go extinct and what types
we expect to thrive first we need to
understand how it is that animals have
been adapting over these past 25 years
and when you understand that this will
all make sense these are the three ways
in which organisms are adapting first is
migration second is behavioral changes
in gene expression shifts and then third
is actual genetic evolution so what
about this migration what's happening
with migration in 2011 a group of
scientists pored through the scientific
literature to find all the data that we
had on animal migrations where it is
that different animal and plant
populations existed over time a lot of
the datasets they had stretched back at
least 25 years so we had quite a bit of
information about where different plants
and animals lived and that was kept
track of sometimes on a yearly basis
sometimes decade basis and so on
what these scientists found is that on
average ecosystems in mountain range
are climbing about 36 feet that's 11
meters per decade and in flat areas
ecosystems on land are shifting about
10.5 miles from the equator so north of
the Equator things are moving further
north in the south of the equator things
are moving further south and it appears
that these ecosystems are doing this
these organisms are doing this because
they're trying to follow good climate
their bodies are adapted to specific
climate circumstances and when the
climate starts to change they get
uncomfortable and they move now you
might be wondering how does a plant
migrate plants and animals are migrating
what the heck is going on there well
plants obviously can't like get up and
walk
they can't just leave an area but from
generation to generation plants do
migrate because their seeds disperse the
seeds that happen to disperse into
better climates for them those
individuals will do better and that's
how we get plants migrating over time so
they can climb mountains like this they
can move all across the the map just
from generation to generation through
seed dispersal a lot of these seeds of
course are dispersed by animals they eat
fruits and then poop them out in
different places
that's actually why plants evolved the
ability to create sweet-tasting shells
around their seeds these things that we
call fruits most types of fruit are
actually in the ovary of the plant and
plants that had ovaries it happen to
taste good we're having their seeds
disbursed further and the further their
seeds were dispersed natural selection
was selecting in favor of that in many
cases and so you have the evolution of
fruit that's that's how this whole crazy
thing got started plants can migrate
animals are migrating on average that's
about 10 miles per decade so about about
a mile per year from the equator now if
you stop and think about this for a
second you realize that there is a
problem and that is that organisms that
live on the tops of mountains like the
beautiful cloud forests of Ecuador
they're screwed because organisms from
lower altitudes are now rising up and
it's it's battle time it's you need a
fight to keep their territory obviously
if you live on an island
you can't really migrate very far unless
you happen to be a bird or something
with wings or you can you're good at
swimming you're kind of stuck on the
island and that's actually where we're
seeing the most extinctions is on
Islands the first mammal that we've seen
that definitely went extinct because of
climate change was an island species of
rat I don't know how much you care about
rats but who has a very unique species
of rat and it's now gone and then of
course in the Arctic so the far north
and the far south you have organisms
that are just having their homes invaded
this is a really interesting photo of a
fox a red fox that has just killed an
arctic fox arctic fox are a little bit
smaller they tend not to do well when
they come in into battle with red foxes
and this guy just just won the war
that's a really cool photo that's by
dawn Guto ski so the main way that
organisms are adapting to climate change
as they are moving and moving of course
causes stress pretty much on everybody
migration is never easy but you enter a
new area and there's always gonna be
someone there already that you have to
fight it puts stress on a species and
then if you add that to other stresses
that we're putting on species with you
know the expansion of cities and
agriculture and so on there's a lot of
things that are playing against species
right now aside from climate change and
if you add that all together it becomes
really difficult for some species to
adapt to this especially if they have
small populations they don't have a lot
of genetic diversity they're probably
not going to make it so ecosystems that
are already on the tops of mountains
they're in a lot of trouble ecosystems
on islands where the organisms in those
ecosystems can't migrate because the
oceans blocking them they're in a lot of
trouble ecosystems in the far north and
in the far south which are now being
invaded by intruders they're in a lot of
trouble so these are the types of
organisms that pretty screwed from
climate change the second way that
organisms are adjusting is through
behavioral changes and gene expression
shifts the key note Checkerspot
butterfly is a species that
I lived in Mexico and Southern
California it left below Los Angeles but
climate change has been causing it to
migrate north
right now it's butting up against LA and
it's having troubles because it can't
really get through this city right
there's this giant city that goes from
the coast all the way to the mountain
range and this butterflied needs to pass
but it can because it's a giant city
there now a lot of the scientists that
are studying this butterfly they're like
whoa this is a problem I think that we
need to actually start capturing them
and moving them ourselves northwest of
LA so that they can continue the
migration northward as the climate
continues to shift but we've found that
this is not necessary and this has been
a huge surprise to everybody that's been
studying this this species is taking
care of itself it's picking itself up by
the bootstraps
apparently it's a libertarian butterfly
species the butterflies are coping in
several different ways first they're
moving further and further up into the
mountains we thought that they would
have problems with this because
butterflies often do if you if you raise
the altitude they don't do well but they
seem to be doing just fine in this case
second they've adopted a new flower as a
host for them to lay their eggs on and
that might not seem like a huge deal if
you are not an entomologist
but butterflies are very sensitive to
diet and wherever they lay their eggs
the the caterpillars will hatch the
larvae will hatch from those eggs and
start eating the plant that they were
laid on and most butterflies are very
very specific they only have one host
plant that they their digestive system
is adapted to use and they specialize on
that and the same is true with this
butterfly it was specializing on one
plant it's now shifted to a new plant
and this happened way faster than we
thought it would so far as we can tell
it happened without any mutation without
any shifts and allele frequency within
the population it seems as though
they're just turning on different genes
and shutting off other genes in order to
cope with this new food product this is
called phenotypic plasticity it's just a
shift in gene expression without
modifying the actual DNA it's not a true
evolution it's just phenotypic
plasticity and then last but not least
we have
actual evolution because phenotypic
plasticity is a real thing and it's very
powerful whenever we see organisms
change in response to their environment
it's hard to tell for sure if they're
actually evolving or if this was just an
ability that they already had in order
to know if something's actually evolving
we usually have to do long-term genetic
studies in 2014 a special issue of the
journal evolutionary applications found
over 20 cases of bona fide evolution
with a strong link to climate change
this is actual evolution at the level of
genes and allele frequencies this is not
simple phenotypic plasticity among the
species that these scientists have found
evolving are the Alaskan pink salmon
which have changed their migration in
their spawning times and this is caused
by a change in their genetics European
snails that have evolved to change the
color of their shells to help them keep
cool in hotter weather and then tawny
owls which are changing their further
colors to better camouflage in their new
browner environments in summary will
animals adapt to climate change
yeah some of them will they already have
been we witness this happening over the
past 25 years and some of them of course
sadly will not those that live on
Islands
tops of mountains the far north of our
south they're gonna have extra troubles
as the climate continues to change I
know that that's pretty sad but here is
a video of some baby raccoons
Chintan mini wildlife center they were
orphaned sadly but the Wildlife Center
took care of them and they were released
back into the wild so that's cool by the
way thank you for bearing with me as I
have a horrible cold today but I made a
film anyways oh my gosh they're so
stinking cute they've met little little
human hands sort of sort of their
fingers almost feel like gel they have
extremely sensitive fingers though
actually the looks for things more with
their hands and with their eyes it's
almost like they see with their hand
they're really cool animals by the way
that make horrible pets their it
adorable when they're babies but as soon
as they go through puberty they they
just turn into nasty little beasts these
things belong in the woods next question
you